any politician will go the wrong way
left to their own devices politicians
will conform in their behavior to the
requirements of voters for the most
fundamental reason of all they want to
keep their job
I have Nikhil SP for reason TV and today
we're talking with Dick Armey and Matt
kibbe authors of give us Liberty a Tea
Party manifesto and the head honchos at
Freedom Works guys thanks for coming
thanks Nick the main central complaint
of the Tea Party movement is that the
government spends too much money what
needs to be cut and how fast actually
the big the complaint is it's too big
and it's too meddlesome this but you
have to cut the government immensely and
as fast as possible give us specific
well obviously the big line is you can't
deal with it unless you deal with
entitlement spending there's one guy
that's stepped up to that is Paul Ryan
he's condemned by the Liberals and
ignored by the Republicans but the fact
is if you just said all government
benefit programs can be voluntary
participation only then all of a sudden
you've got people voluntarily saying
we'll take me off your list of unfunded
mandates for Medicare and Social
Security by the way there's a bunch of
low-hanging fruits you could you could
repeal Obamacare you could repeal tarp
you could repeal Fannie and Freddie and
these are all big fiscal time bombs but
I think you need to cap discretionary
spending as well and by the way defense
shouldn't be held harmless if you limit
the overall growth in a budget you're
gonna force some efficiencies that's
essential well it historically defense
spending is where the big cuts come but
you could do for example I mean there
you got inane programs like AmeriCorps
get rid of it it's I mean there's it's
absurd to begin with you can BBS and all
and endowment of this art and that art
and so forth agriculture policy in the
discretionary section of the budget
there's much that can be done so
politically what has to happen because
on a certain level what you're saying is
standard you know kind of limited
government rhetoric why is it gonna work
now when it
work under Bush responsibility on
spending has now become the defining
issue in politics and this whole
movement this whole Tea Party movement
is there to hold politicians accountable
they've replaced a lot of big spending
Republicans and we like to say that
November 3rd is more important than
November 2nd because all politicians
left to their own devices will spend
money they don't have so these guys have
to show up the Tea Party has to show up
after the election and hold them
accountable and I think politicians more
often not give their vote to the person
they fear the most where they're going
to be now more afraid of the advocates
of limited government than they are of
the advocates of the pork group that's
one of the archetypal images from the
the Tea Party March last year was
government get out of my Medicare which
suggests there's a certain level of
confusion among the tea party
rank-and-file do they understand what
even at all okay there is as you might
guess confusion among liberals because
they can't understand any idea that's
deeper than the water on the plate but
what they're saying is look you forced
me in the Medicare I have no choice you
punish anybody that would give me
medical services and take payment other
than my Medicare so it's really give me
liberty or give me death with Medicare
now don't come in here and cut my
Medicare so you can expand your
compulsive mandates on all the
population and there's a big difference
between don't cut my benefits and don't
cut Medicare if in fact you if I'd were
to be free to choose to stay in this
program then make good on your
commitment but if you leave others to be
free to leave there will be more money
available for the making of that
commitment let's talk a little bit about
politics despite being extremely
unpopular Harry Reid is basically you
know running neck-and-neck with the
Challenger you know many incumbents are
already doing well Larry Sabato the
political scientist said it's looking
like the incumbency rates gonna be
around 92% which is slightly down from
an average of about 95 98 percent you
know is what's gonna happen in the
midterms I think it's going to be a big
wave of independent voters that are
gonna change these elections right and I
don't imagine how anybody can say the
incumbent
92% is probably getting pretty close to
that right now and just the income and
centers that are retired or lost their
seat in primaries so an incumbent
retention rate of 92% I think is the
person who makes that point has just
described it discredited episode in your
in your book you talk a lot about how
the Tea Party movement has to take over
the Republican Party what assurances do
we have or do we need that they'll
govern differently this time than the
last time under Bush the Republicans
were terrible they essentially colluded
to increase discretionary federal
expenditures by a hundred percent what's
gonna be different this time well first
of all this movement is transforming
Congress is a bottom-up movement and
politicians will conform in their
behavior to the requirements of voters
for the most fundamental reason well
they want to keep their job we call it a
hostile takeover the Republican Party by
the way and there's two parts of that
process first is personnel changes and
we're replacing senators like Bennet
with senators like Lee and the second
part is our ability like you say to hold
these politicians accountable because
any politician will go the wrong way
left to their own devices so how central
is Sarah Palin and her endorsements
particular candidates to to the Tea
Party movement well my guess is that
when Sarah Palin gets in the endorsement
business she's probably doing it's
pretty much the same thing we're doing
listening to the real actives that
really live in the state or district and
getting their information about what is
the quality of the two candidates and
what what races races may be winnable
rather than listening to the
professionals in the political party
that are detached removed and simply
frankly don't know we have known better
about what's been going on in Republican
primary politics over the past two years
of the Republican Party why because we
listen to real people I think Sarah
Palin's doing the same thing yeah but
she's no longer she's no more the Tea
Party leader than Dick Armey or Matt
kibbe are and it's a it's a leaderless
movement but you are seeing this this
movement represents a stage and you're
seeing a lot of candidates climb up on
that stage and I say let the more
leaders the better where's the Tea Party
stand on abortion
you know foreign foreign affairs drug
legalization terrorism immigration I
think I think the Tea Party movement is
focused on fiscal issues and all of
those issues are kind of outside that
core set of issues that unites us and
let me say one of the things that makes
this movements so refreshing on the
field of political activities Lee is
this enormous tolerance for diversified
IO pinyin so we don't look at the guy
next to as said you got to agree with me
on this issue of that issue but there's
a natural unity on the big issues that
are compelling the voters in America are
you going to be able to maintain that
because already we see certain elements
of the Tea Party going down to the
Arizona border and and supporting
Arizona's immigration bill you know it's
I mean it seems like politics always
starts to put its nose under the tent
right know they're free to do that it's
all in the immigration bill particularly
as you look at this the state of Arizona
saying I will defend my borders in the
absence of a government that's a federal
government that's effective these are
serious policy matters and quite frankly
within this movement that you're free to
choose if that's a priority that you
have as an individual gold be active on
behalf of that priority that doesn't
mean that they won't also show up when
it comes time to balance the budget they
may in fact be very disappointed in a
person in office on this issue while
they applaud for example of John McCain
on his commitment to stop earmarks if
the Tea Party is successful what will
America or what will government look
like I think I think the tea party if it
succeeds is a sustainable community and
it's got to be there and it's and we got
to get out of political space because
nobody pays attention to politics in the
real world into cultural space and it's
got to be fun and it's got to be a way
for people to stay engaged in the
political what do you mean by cultural
space cultural space is if you go to a
tea party there's there's more music
than there are can political speeches
and it's it's more like a football game
I like to say it's more like the parking
lot at a Grateful Dead concert but
leader army may disagree with me on well
they
members call a tailgate party which we
think is better than dead heads but then
still nevertheless they were George
Strait where to show up we'd celebrate
him that's right
and then finally who wrote the sex
scenes in this book because they were
incredibly disgusting we contracted out
on that that's I bet you kept it within
American borders or get them for both
felt like we should limit ourselves to
things we really knew something about so
we needed to get somebody down come in
and work on that would explain the lack
of sex scenes
absolutely I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason
TV I want to thank a former leader of
majority leader of Congress Dick Armey a
head of freedom works along with Matt
kibbe also a freedom works and the
authors of the new best-selling book
give us Liberty a Tea Party manifesto
Thanks